[Musica]
è una notte di mezza estate vi trovate
in spiaggia e avete questo spettacolo
davanti a voi questa volta celeste
ovviamente siete attratti da dalle
stelle da questa miriade di stelle
sapete da questo sono attratto quando
guardo uno scenario come questo
dall esatto opposto dal buio perché è
nell'oscurità che si cela il mistero
tutto ciò che deve essere ancora
scoperto quello cui dobbiamo puntare per
evolverci come umanità per esplorare
prendere sempre oltre
da piccolo non facevo altro che correre
verso stanze buie per caso questo dico
che voi senza motivo ma il motivo
principale perché come come sfogo la mia
il mio gol è stato sempre quello di
capire i misteri del cosmo che il
prossimo passo che dobbiamo comunque
fare come umanità perché questo il
sistema solare e noi ci troviamo sulla
terra un piccolo pianetino punto in cui
tutto esiste tutta la vita è sempre
esistita e un piccolo punto ma se le
risorse finiscono o se un asteroide rock
rotta di collisione con la terra o se
c'è un virus che non riusciamo più a
fermare qual è il piano b dobbiamo avere
un pianeta un altro pianeta un piano b
in cui evacuare in casa e noi siamo
particolarmente interessati a quel
puntino rosso che si chiama marte mars
in inglese
perché ma soprattutto riusciremo mai ad
andarci finora nessuno è mandato su
marte a parte robo o sonde ma come umani
riusciremo mai ad andarci se potreste
fare una domanda a una persona nel
medioevo dire fra note un giorno andremo
sulla piena sulla luna ovviamente si
metterebbe ridere no impossibile però
sappiamo bene com'è andata dopo quindi è
possibile che il concetto di impossibile
sia legato al tempo cioè che questa
parola in realtà non esiste perché è
impossibile andare sulla luna in un
tempo come il medioevo ma ci siamo
andati sulla luna
quindi è solo una questione di tempo
arriveremo su marte prima o poi ma
perché siamo così interessate a marte e
non gli altri panetti non avvennero no
mercurio semplicemente perché marte è
più facile come pianeta da rendere
abitabile rispetto alla terra rispetto
alla venere mercurio sono pianeti
terrestri giove saturno eccetera sono
pianeti gassosi
per quale motivo se guardiamo questa
immagine
la parte in rosso evidenzia un'area in
cui che è troppo vicino al sole in cui
l'acqua non è stabile in forma liquida e
mai papola l'acqua il colore in blu
verso la fine di questo disco è l'area
in cui la temperatura è troppo fredda
quindi l'acqua esterne sono in forma e
ghiacciata
la parte in verde l'unica parte in cui
potremmo sopravvivere perché l'alcol
forma liquida dell'acqua essenziale per
tutti tutti gli esseri viventi bene
ma l'acqua punto dove l'acqua su marte
perché non c'è l'acqua liquida perché
marte non ha un'atmosfera l'ha persa la
testa circa 3 miliardi di anni fa
se noi dovessimo l'atmosfera alla nostra
terra dove sappiamo che c'è l'acqua
liquida l'acqua likud evaporerebbe
perché non è più tenuta stabile della
pressione dell'atmosfera
questo è quello che è successo a marte
di cosa è fatto mark praticamente rocce
vulcaniche lava
pensate alle rocce dell'etna le lave
dell'etna oppure lav e delle hawaii e
molto simili alle navi della wuyong però
sono molto più ricche in ferro questo è
perché vedete marche rosso perché c'è
polvere arrugginita in giro per pianeta
come sappiamo tutte queste cose
due motivi principali 1 sono le missioni
spaziali come sempre quello della nasa e
dell'esa che mandano rover sonde
analizzare la superficie direttamente
sul pianeta
altri sono analisi di campioni marziani
che arrivano sulla terra come meteoriti
perché non abbiamo mai preso un campione
da marte e l'abbiamo riportato sulla
terra
questo non è mai successo finora questi
pezzi di marte come fanno ad arrivare
sulla terra per magia no praticamente
quando un asteroide impatto sulla
superficie di marte espelle frammenti
nello spazio quando questi frammenti
incontrano l'orbita terrestre per
gravità cadono sulla superficie poi
possono essere trovati e raccolti io ho
la straordinaria fortuna di fare questo
come lavoro cioè io tocco marte ogni
giorno praticamente oggi anche voi avete
questa fortuna perché ho qui con me un
pezzo di morte poi potrete poi potrete
dare uno sguardo durante la pausa di
vuole è un pezzo di lava eruttata su
marte da alcuni vulcani ora perché siamo
tanti interessati alle rocce perché
questa è una una roccia
immaginate una roccia sulla superficie
terrestre questa roccia ha vissuto per
milioni di anni ha vissuto cambiamenti
climatici glaciazioni inondazioni
innalzamento del livello del mare guerre
stellari
alla fine dopo anni anni nel 2085 un
geologo del futuro la trova e l'analizza
è tutto ciò che questa roccia ha vissuto
il registrato nella sua chimica in
questo senso un viaggio un geologo e un
viaggiatore del tempo perché ogni
minerale presente in questa roccia a
delle storie incredibili da raccontare
ecco perché
immaginate una roccia marziana quante
cose da dirci su quell ambiente queste
questi meteoriti è facile trovarli nei
deserti sia calda sia fredda quello sono
io nel deserto del sahara vicino al
luogo di impatto di questa meteorite
marziano cercando di trovare altri pezzi
quello non sono io in antartide
però spero di andarci qualche volta
perché la nasa fa le spedizioni ogni
anno a cercare meteoriti bene questo
come dicevo il mio lavoro non mi ci sono
mai abituato perché ogni volta poi in
mano un pezzo di marte è una sensazione
stranissima è analizzarlo e come stare
facendo il lavoro di qualcuno in un
lontano futuro se in cui abbiamo già
colonizzato il cane per os
ora vi accenno solo a due delle ultime
scoperte che ho fatto che possono essere
utili per l'umanità del futuro in caso
colonizzare mo marche alcune sono già
rese pubbliche altre ancora no però io
mi faccio solo alcuni accenni c'è ad
esempio il primo studiando questa
meteorite che viene dal mantello di
marzo proprio dalle parti più interne di
marte ho trovato a quali condizioni
temperatura con i minerali si sono
formati quindi ho scoperto che marte
potrebbe essere ancora attivo oggi come
pianeta
quindi questo significherebbe che se
andiamo lì e speriamo le prime basi
umane potremmo utilizzare energia
geotermica energia geotermica per
riscaldare le basi per l'elettricità e
sarebbe una grande cosa
altra cosa è ora che vedete in foto è
l'entrata di un tunnel lavico su marte
come dicevo marche tutto in superficie
l'africa fatto da volcani quale vediamo
meglio in sezione trasversale
se tagliamo questo tunnel di lava
vediamo il suo interno
vediamo che c'è un tetto basalto è il
nome della roccia della lava bene quello
che ho provato e analizzando un pezzo di
lava che viene dalle parti dal tetto di
questo tunnel di lava ci ho trovato cioè
non ho trovato evidenze di interazione
con pericolosi raggi solari o raggi
cosmici che arrivano dall atmosfera
significa praticamente che se noi un
giorno andassimo su marte senza una casa
potremmo comunque insediarsi in questi
tunnel di lava essere protetti dalle
radiazioni mortali perché mark non
avendo un atmosfera si colpirebbe in
modo mortale con le sue relazioni quindi
qui possiamo essere
figurano queste queste tonnellate ma
l'acqua l'acqua essenziale per
sopravvivere no per generare delle serre
anche in cui possiamo utilizzare
possiamo creare cibo nelle basi
riciclare l'acqua eccetera eccetera
quindi dove si trova allora quello che
vediamo non vediamo l'altro perché
guardiamo a martin tre dimensioni no
cosa sto dicendo veramente noi viviamo
in una realtà e tre dimensioni o una
certa altezza una certa larghezza una
certa profondità no ma se aggiungiamo
un'altra dimensione abbiamo il tempo e
la geologia un'efficienza in quattro
dimensioni perché se noi vivessimo in
una realtà in quattro dimensioni
potremmo vedere per un singolo oggetto
il suo passato presente in futuro in un
attimo se potrei potremmo vedere la
nascita la vita e la morte di una
persona in un singolo nata attimo in
realtà e quattro dimensioni ad effetti
questo significa che se noi compriamo
marche in quattro dimensioni possiamo
vedere tutta la sua storia geologica al
tempo zero marte stava ancora formando
quindi ero un oceano di magma a tempo
medio marte o cosa cella c'è un oceano
sono oggi anni e laghi incredibile
sembra la terra però poi al tempo 1 mar
aveva perso l'atmosfera quindi come lo
vediamo oggi ma dove sono finiti tutta
tutte l'acqua e laghi dove sono finiti
l'acqua e serve per terra formare ma
anche noi dobbiamo cercare di ri
trasformare marty a quello stadio
quindi dove diamine finita l'acqua ce
n'è ancora lì ma non si vede non si vede
perché si trova sotto la superficie ed è
allo stato di ghiaccio non è acqua
liquida
quindi come facciamo ad estrarla noi
come umani siamo bravi a distruggere
pianeti non siamo bravi a trasformare i
pianeti luoghi abitabili noi noi è
praticamente stiamo generando
riscaldamento globale
mettiamo anche carbonica nell'atmosfera
tutte queste cose ma sorpresa è proprio
quello che dobbiamo fare per marte
quindi si va bene perché quello che
dobbiamo fare e immettere anidride
carbonica nell'atmosfera generare
l'effetto serra e in questo modo
mettiamo la temperatura quindi tutta
l'acqua presente sia stato di gag sotto
la superficie ritornerà in superficie
quindi avremo marte ritrasformato le
condizioni in cui aveva un oceano laghi
come una volta
bene quanti anni ci vorrà cose ci vorrà
per fare questo prima di tutto possiamo
utilizzare ad esempio delle parabole che
cercano di deviare i raggi solari e fare
in modo che colpiscano marche per fare
una cosa del genere
cento anni ce la faremo no mille anni
sembrano tantissimi un umano però per
questo tipo di cose non bastano 10 mila
anni
non bastano nemmeno per un pianeta
il modo in cui l'atmosfera si autoregola
ci volevano migliore ci vuole almeno un
milione di anni per fare una cosa del
genere per terra formare marte a formare
un pianeta in generale ma non solo per
la geologia in sé anche per la
tecnologia che ancora non abbiamo a
portata di mano
servirebbe l'esempio che come umani
arrivassimo creare delle cose
fantascientifiche come delle sfere in
grado di catturare tutte l'energia della
nostra stella sole insomma stiamo
parlando veramente di futuro remoto non
futuro prossimo
veramente futuro lontano quindi saremo
tutti i marziani
oppure siamo già tutti i marziani
allora se la vita non sappiamo ancora se
c'è vita su marte
ma se la vita è nata su marte è nata
prima che sulla terra perché sulla terra
la vita è apparsa circa 3.8 miliardi
d'anni fa ancora non siamo proprio
sicuri 3.3 miliardi di anni fa
se sommati a passare a vita la metà
della vita apparsa 4.1 miliardi di anni
fa forse pure prima e vi ho detto
un'altra cosa durante questa
presentazione vi ho detto che abbiamo
meteoriti che arrivano da mark sulla
terra quindi fate due più due
secondo un processo chiamato panspermia
c'è una remota possibilità che in
passato se c'è stata vita su marte un
asteroide ha colpito la superficie di
marte con la vita marziana dentro la
portata sulla terra e noi ci siamo
evoluti da quella vita quindi noi
saremmo tutti i marziani senza nemmeno
saperlo è per questo che il mio istinto
primordiale è stato sempre è quello di
studiare il buio c'è l'oscurità perché
non è solo il mio istinto cioè è
l'istinto di tutti noi come esseri umani
perché noi siamo esploratori lo siamo
sempre stati e tutte le domande
riguardo chi siamo dove da dove veniamo
dove andremo sono lì fuori non è su
marte che stiamo andando
stiamo andando a scoprire noi stessi
[Applauso]